déjà mon travail et c'est le pho 24
heures par jour 7 jours par semaine ce
qui est important c'est que notre ville
soit propre et ça je peux accepter que
leur ville soit elle peut pas accepter
que hank les citoyens fonction des
comportements la campagne de lancement
aura lieu du 12 avril au 15 mai pendant
cette période un membre du service des
incendies de montréal passera visiter
chaque foyer pour remettre un message
que le maire adresse à chaque citoyen
lui demandant sa coopération personnel
pour faire un grand ménage une campagne
d'embellissement nettoyage la plus vaste
qui a jamais eu lieu ni à montréal ni
sur ce continent
nous demandons à tous les citoyens de
vider leurs câbles rengard leurs
couleurs galerie de tout ce qu'ils y ont
accumulé depuis peut-être plusieurs
années et dont il s'empresse de faire
parce qu'ils n'ont plus besoin ils se
rencontrent et inutiles et du 10 au 15
mai des centaines de camions de la voie
publique passeront chaque jour sur
chaque lui non pas deux fois par semaine
chaque jour sur chaque lieu du 10 au 15
mai pour enlever tout ce qu'est les
citoyens auront sortis de leurs maisons
or ont enlevé deux de leurs cours ou des
terres et vague qui sont autour de leur
maison et tous les articles qu'on a
ainsi enlevé seront transportés place
radio-canada rue dorchester est et le 15
mai à 10 heures du soir un grand feu de
joie se représenter comme symboles de la
joie tous les montréalais ans de
participer au nettoyage des maisons et à
l'embellissement de la ville